scotland has rejected independence
scotland's referendum should have been
the warning sign
yet a new report says the government
failed to protect the brexit vote from
the threat
of russian interference a cautious
approach by spy agencies
also condemned as illogical the
committee found it astonishing
that no one in government had sought
beforehand to protect the referendum
from such attempts or investigated
afterwards what attempts to influence it
there may have been do you also think
that the spy chiefs
the the spy masters who are in charge of
the agencies
should have been more forceful in
gripping what you describe as a hot
potato
yes mi5 perhaps should have done this
work
one would have assumed someone at the
heart of government
might have wanted to know if the
efficacy
of democratic processes in the uk was
being undermined
the report said uk spies saw russia's
hand in the u.s
election as a game changer but the
intelligence and security committee
criticized this as a belated response
the government also under fire for then
delaying the publication
of the very report making these findings
i still remain utterly bemused
and also angry and troubled that the
government decided
quite deliberately to prevent it being
published for nine months
and that worries me about the mindset of
the government of course it does
there was no good reason to do that the
report also accuses russia of cyber
attacks and physical ones like the
salisbury spy poisoning
concern too about wealthy russians
linked to president putin
securing influence in the uk only a
small group of parliamentarians have a
window into
the uk's secret intelligence world their
reports
like this one carry weight and heat
not just for ministers but sometimes for
spieties too
the russia report says that the
government until recently
had badly underestimated the russian
threat and the response it required
the foreign secretary rejected
suggestions the uk failed to investigate
russia
we've got a long period recognizing the
enduring and significant threat posed
by russia to the uk including in
relation to cyber
russia is a top national security
priority
moscow's man in london dismissed the
russia report as fiction
it's much of error about nothing
and the report is called russia
it is on the first page here but if you
will
put any others country's name uh it will
it will be about the same
because this report is not about russia
it is about
internal relationship of different
agencies uh
that are doing intelligence inside the
uk did russia
amplify the division during the brexit
have no means to amplify anything as i
said for the division division is bad
amplifying it is also bad boris johnson
has rejected calls to investigate the eu
referendum
ministers saying there's no evidence of
successful
interference but perhaps that's just
because they've not been looking
debrahing sky news